so if you look at urban systems today
they basically have a whole bunch of
systems traditionally speaking have been
designed and continue to be operated
essentially independent from one another
so the question is do these things need
to continue to operate independently can
we actually make them or the city work
much better be planned much better be
operated much better when the systems
can actually talk to each other
communicate with each other and
coordinate with one another so a smart
city would be a metropolitan region and
urban region where all the constituent
component systems are able to
communicate cooperate and coordinate any
innovations technologies and policies
that would actually make a city smarter
more functional more flexible could
actually have global implications and
global applications and global adoption
so we would like to basically have
Pittsburgh be an exemplar smart city in
the country and in the world and we want
CMU to basically become innovation
leader in this context
you